Super Bowl 53 will go down in the annals
of history as one of the greatest games
ever played a total combined score of 16
points many times you look at the people
at your house and go what the hell are
we watching all right I'm just gonna be
honest I can't I don't want to try it
like I'm hoping that I'm coming in here
today and that Chris Sims is gonna tell
me that it was actually Loki one of the
greatest Super Bowls ever and he can't
wait to watch the film nope I'm not
negative ghostrider but I did enjoy it I
mean I enjoyed that that you know it was
a chess match that every defensive
struggle yeah I mean I certainly wasn't
in 113 to 3 but because 1710 I could
have been happy with I tweeted out I was
like you couldn't pay me a hundred
dollars to watch this game again right
and the amount of tweets that I got were
hey appreciate the defensive struggle
look at all the great plays and I go
just because not a lot of points are
scored does not mean it was a defensive
struggle when there are seven three and
outs it's also poor execution sure when
I'm watching Jared Goff taking sacks for
no reason when he's held the ball for 12
seconds okay fine maybe the coverage is
good but I'm also watching offense his
inability to make plays right so I I
felt dirty
I felt cheated and I'm also gonna say
this I don't think that was a Super Bowl
and I'm not saying that Rams Saints was
the super oh I'm not saying that
Patriots Chiefs I'm saying that it
shouldn't count and thus the
Philadelphia Eagles are still your world
champ okay sorry sorry buddy that's not
happening
but but was it more and we're gonna we
have something to get to but just really
quick is it is it more defensive
struggle or bad execution no I mean I
think it's a little bit of both I do
think it's more defensive struggle
though I do I think the defense and what
Belichick did defensively was phenomenal
I think we saw two quarterbacks who were
not that great
not again before we start attacking
Chris Sims it's just these aren't the
top five quarterbacks in football
they're you know Brady you could argue
as edge of top ten I would say right and
I believe that Jared Goff is the Mendoza
line in the NFL basically I believe that
Jared Goff is he where 16 of the 32 he
is 16 I feel like if you're better than
Jared Goff you're good if you're worse
you're probably not yep I mean I think
that's fair I mean there's you know
again to bring it back full circle I
mean last year remember we were 28
touchdowns seven interceptions all this
oh yeah he's the best he's the best no
he was not
that's why I had him 20th last year if
you remember after the season or going
in this season it wasn't a knock on him
but you could see once again when
McVeigh doesn't dial up Oh Todd Gurley
screens and the run game doesn't work
he's not the type of talent that's going
to carry a squad that's not what he's
capable of but regardless we do have to
give a lot of credit to both defenses of
course both of those defenses are
phenomenally coached and have a lot of
superfreaks
and that is what really led to one of
the most boring games yeah I'm seeing a
lot of people talk about how the
Patriots played a six by one up front
they yet took to cover the edges is what
we talked about and then playing quarter
quarters in the back was awesome but you
look in and we're gonna break down the
game more fully after this but I also
thought that one team hit on their seam
throws from like 35 yards out and the
other team missed Robert Crumb Kowski
caught his and Brandon cooks dropped his
and that was seven points and that was
really difference in the game yeah yeah
I mean it was a great defensive play by
the you know Darren Harmon who came over
I was a tough catch if we're also the
Jared Goff throwing it lay down the
middle and someone they should have had
I mean Jared Goff threw a duck he threw
an Aflac and if he threw a rocket or a
rifle that would have been a touchdown
and then we would have been into a
different type of game I feel like we
got some tweets about people saying who
would have who threw that ball better
golf or left go some of those I feel
like look if I could throw it 49 I could
have thrown that one on I just saw your
dad threw an underhand ball on the
pregame show you heard it yep big Phil
can do that man
he could legitimately throw it a 40 or
we know it was whistling yeah I was
hanging out with Travis Kelce who was on
the set when that happened right and
Kelsey goes dude it was so cold and that
was a brand new ball out of the box yeah
he's like as soon as he released that I
was like I really hope he doesn't take
somebody's head I was thinking this is
that ball out of the box is gonna be a
rock I can be selective I want us give
the most sincere thank you
to a lot of the people at this company
that helped us do what we did at Dan
Tana's everyone involved in the show
from Todd and Matt and Karen and Nicole
and Sean and the editor Julian who's
been working with us with the show the
entire time who really I thought with
the Odell thing that we did and a bunch
of that stuff was awesome everyone that
went down there and helped out all the
people at Turner they're helping out
Josh you were a huge part of it and
going down there and finding the area
and and setting it all up and running
show you were amazing Oh Joshy I want to
give a super sincere shout out to Paris
who booked us so many of the guests that
we've got on the show and I think part
of the reason it was so different and
when I say show me a podcast and show
because we didn't have really any plugs
the only plugs was JJ Watt and he said
the f-word or you did the S word right
so it was great so we didn't have to you
know I didn't go to radio I went to
radio one time to see you in the
beginning right because it was so nice
to not be there yeah and then the other
part of the thank you goes to all the
people that showed up like we had fans
that showed up Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday and man that's the
reason we do what we do
yeah because it was so cool to have you
there it was so cool for you to see how
we interact with people to just talk to
you guys to answer your questions it was
it was really really special Harris his
uncle is Robert Griffith I mean that's
he was a big-time safety in the end of
the 90s for the Vikings I got to meet
him I was like a shocking revelation
yeah he was phenomenally cool yeah I did
not know it he was there with us you
said hi - we were walking in yes exactly
right I mean because I thought I heard
right the first time but I didn't want
to be rude when he introduced himself
like wait wait what who say that again
that's so fun then I violin I don't know
why later I was like wait so Paris Paris
was a baller but I didn't realize her
uncle was a baller - yeah like Vic and -
Shawn and well everybody we got was so
cool Kurt cousins at one time was
standing outside just watching a pair of
no one said a word to him we did we did
yeah cuz we knew who he was but he was
just chilling it really is like if Josh
was a few inches taller and we were
dressed exactly the same oh yeah I was
wearing a plaid button-down shirt he was
wearing the same yeah
he made a google document for his
weekend trip there I always look at guys
like her cousins to go like what the
[ __ ] you doing here man you made like 34
million dollars this year is this like
you really is it worth the hundred
thousand dollars he probably made from
the hearing her cousin's talking his
mind yet oh no it sounds like he will
literally pick up every cent on the
sidewalk if he has to he drives a
conversion video his number in his bank
account apparently that's all he cares
about is what the number is because he
doesn't spend it he just wants to see it
go I am which I don't understand either
well I'm very curious about how Kirk is
gonna live his life after football right
is he planning on investing that or do
you think he's gonna sit there and go
nobody touches my money he's like some
of my Wall Street friends who just want
to die with a big number and I want a
big what's the point of making all of it
if you never do anything fun with it
yeah but it was a lot of fun all right
so we have to do something that sucks
and I if I lose my [ __ ] I lose my [ __ ]
you're a meme and already it's that's
what's happening so what we had was a
very special week for Simms and Lefko
but I also have to tell you guys that is
the final week of Sims and Lefko and the
show that in which it currently exists
is not going to be that way anymore Sims
we all know how great he is and how hard
he works now especially is hangin deep
breath it's ok Bert it's alright you've
been offered an incredible opportunity
yeah we are so excited for you and we
want you to share that well yes this
this will be my last week working at
bleacher report and I say that with a
very heavy heart heavy heart of course
it's bittersweet I'm going to announce
where I'm going on Wednesday that'll
come later this week but yes I was
offered a great opportunity and it's a
shame because I never envisioned that
happening this way this is a special
place Bleacher Report all define people
that work here and have worked here have
helped mold me and make me
into what I am in my career right now
which is a guy that watches football and
has a big mouth they gave me the
JumpStart there and let go you of course
we're a huge part in that and harvesting
some of those thoughts out of my brain
and making me talk and act upon them
when you read notes of mine or had
conversations and Josh of course
starting the podcast in general this
none of this happens without you too so
not only am i thankful for working here
at bleacher report it's so sad to say to
our fans and what we built and everybody
in this office at Bleacher Airport is
amazing
but more importantly you two are amazing
and I hope you know that
yeah like special special people special
work co-workers I should say and other
than left go being a little late like on
days today where he wanted eat breakfast
instead of getting here on top I just
really try to avoid this whole thing if
I went to a therapist later there we go
I was not late because I was no I just
didn't want to come to work tonight okay
but but either way it is it is it was a
great privilege and opportunity to work
with you guys and work at this company
that's a bleacher report which is made
waves and really molded me like I said
and it is it's a sad time but also a
happy time I want to say this to to
everyone that's listening who I'm sure
is shocked this podcast is not going to
end because what we've created I believe
is the best community of football fans
that exists you guys are smart you guys
understand it you're not too emotional
but you also embrace your fan hood we
enjoy having fun and I think that in
Sims is honor we're gonna keep this
thing rolling the way that I've always
seen it is 33 33 33 percent you know
what I mean and with Sims gone I want to
bring the homies into the fold I want
you guys to have the percentages because
you guys have always been the reason
that this thing exists so we are going
to be doing two more podcast this week
one more where the big [ __ ] is going
to come in here we're
have a good time and talk about the game
more in detail and just shoot it up and
then we want you guys to get your last
stuff in so Thursday we're gonna record
a mailbag that's gonna come out Friday
and we'll go for you know our hour and a
half like we normally do just answering
questions and all that stuff and then
starting next week I'm still going to be
doing the podcast but I it would be an
insult for me to try and do it exactly
the way it's done because that's how
good at Sims is that what he does so I'm
doing two things one I've kind of
created a nice little rolodex of
athletes that I like to talk to well and
we're gonna keep going with that too I
think it's it's my duty to keep
everybody informed on what's going on
the NFL sure and kind of keep that going
and and find a new way to make this
creative but the homies have a job and
the job is to talk to me and what I mean
by that is keep getting in the DMS keep
getting in the YouTube comments more
than ever before I am gonna dedicate a
lot of the show to you guys everything
that I've ever done well in my life is
by listening to people when I blew up in
Louisville and got the job in bleacher
report it's because I was interacting
with people online
when Sims and left go I think really
took off is when me and Josh truly
started listening to the DMS the YouTube
comments and just interacting with you
guys so really I'm giving you guys a lot
of power in it right now because unless
it's Sims or Fender ik that's really the
only people I want to give it to her the
homies that's just the truth area so if
you would like to come on at another
time sure we're gonna do that I don't
think that's crazy now um I hope all the
homies all the homies out there please
continue to listen to left go left goes
as good as it gets in the business he
loves football he has a true passion
about it he's has a good feel for it
organically anyways let alone I'd like
to think I taught him a few things you
swore that are important in any game and
I hope some of the homies come over and
listen to me I can't announce where I'm
going in and the powers to be or may be
no thank you
but it doesn't mean that you have to
pick me or let go no we're still homie
no if you don't think I'm gonna be
listening to Sims and stealing his ideas
even when he's somewhere else you're
actually crazy
my number one promise though I will
never pretend like I know exactly what's
going on
this isn't gonna become Steven a Smith
where I get up here and go on like 20
minute rants Posterous yeah like like
I'm not gonna all of a sudden realize
like this entire podcast has been me
asking you and like diving into your
brain I'm not all of a sudden gonna go I
was a cover to show with no that's all
right but you know left go with didn't
you doing that a lot of the times you
were able to formulate my X's and O's
beats in the weeds stuff yes and make
very good common sense out of it at
times where I could get lost no ease and
that's why you became the betting guy
and that's why you beat me most years in
betting I waited so long to say this it
really is incredible that I in the last
game we could possibly go you know what
though I'm glad you got something so we
finished three to one but the Patriots
it it was let's get back to the game oh
wait is there anything you'd like to say
I'm gonna try no cuz then I'll just
start crying hysterically so thank you
to both of you yes been an incredible
couple years watching you over the last
couple years blow up has been absurd and
you as well left go and the two of you
together yeah bittersweet but I don't
want to start crying so let's talk about
Super Bowl yeah okay um where did you
watch at my house okay yep Joe's stone
crab on the menu no didn't happen didn't
happen the wife Salt Lake nope we didn't
do that either I know I don't know
that's what I thought he said it was
importing Salt Lake from that was the
game plan but no Charlotte
horseback-riding fill a basketball game
I would say got on the couch about 4:45
five o'clock sitting on the cloud yeah
and started out with some you know
celery carrots dip chips queso sauce saw
all that went to chicken wings just the
immediate femme
that's just us for now
us four together and it was great it
really was I mean Danielle and my little
girl sat there the whole game Philip did
- other than halftime he went up to like
get a game of maddening real quick at
halftime I wish I had a game of madden
instead of maroon 5 great I did you hate
did you I didn't I thought it was okay I
don't really examine room five no but
that it was okay but I found it
entertaining I don't know I guess my
thing how did you watch the game well
get back to halftime right yeah I just
wanted my friends over my apartment nice
about 15 people over cook did not make
pigs in a blanket every time I've been
to Josh's pigs were black I had him but
we had so much food I didn't make him
but you know what I did get well I was
on the VIP list at Dan and John so i
pre-ordered my wings like four weeks ago
that's a Dan and John's
so I walked in when we had our Odell
Rogers Draft Josh's favorite wing place
in the city I walked in to pick up my
wings and Dan is sitting there and I say
Josh vendrick here to pick up my hundred
wings 50 hot so 33 hot 33 spicy barbeque
33 medium so you do the wings like I do
the podcast was perfect yeah and he goes
hey aren't you you're the guy from from
the podcast right and I go that's me
I appreciate it cuz Dan and Jon's they
comment on our instagrams so you have a
little social media relationship going
on yeah yeah he knows what's up wait is
what were the three flavors hot spicy
barbeque and medium that's the way to go
if we were if there we were the three
flavors which one will be hot which
won't be spicy barbecue much will be
medium definitely medium over here this
guy started sweating eating mild wings
from Dan Tana's like and then the next
day went I'd like another order I'm like
you're I'm obviously hot and you're
spicy barbecue I think that I I had no
idea what to do for the game yesterday
right because I had a credential but I
refused to sit in the media room to
watch a Super Bowl right like oh you get
in the stadium that's really really cool
but like this is just me I have no
interest in sitting in a room in silence
with other people in the media yeah all
like trying to impress each other and
I'm not saying this like I'm holier than
thou it's just I either I'm it's either
my team and I want to have a ticket or I
want to be in a comfortable place so I
went to I went to this like Ric Flair
event and I got to see Ric and I've met
him a
few times so it would he was he's the
man dude Ric Flair is a legend he seems
like it after that your boy Rosner kind
of hooked me up with this like tailgate
thing and then my friend Dan Newmark
who's a big-time Rams fan I got him and
his mom and his friend in there and he
actually created the show with Travis
Kelce the catching Kelsey right so he's
like you know Kelsey's hitting me up
right now and I just told him I'm with
you and he wants to come so Travis came
over ambushed by fans like he is he is
sorry he up but he's got a recognizable
face and he's like six-six and he's cool
and this is a little bit of a humble
brag but I went to Kelsey's house with
my girlfriend and he had a bunch of
friends over and he's a house in Atlanta
he like had an air beat yeah I played a
little beer pong yeah
won five games in a row I am some other
guy that was there it was cool because
you know when Gronk does stuff Kelsey
can is like immediate like oh did you
see what he did there oh that's pretty
awesome but I I had a hard time enjoying
the game like I said that time you know
my bad sorry
so halftime I got excited for him yeah I
got more excited when the Travis Scott
spongebob
meteor thing came down school and then
when he hit I was like this is gonna be
great but I didn't even think Travis
Scott was that good it was very quick I
just feel like the Super Bowl is made
for television right and I feel like
it's usually over-the-top so Beyonce at
Super Bowl 50 we were at she had the
whole line dancing and Bruno Mars also
when we were there yes the second one
yes Bruno has put on some really good
shows he has to think about Bruno is
he's gonna have five guys up there in
unison and it's gonna be good music to
Lady Gaga heard jumping off the roof
last year and then doing all that stuff
yeah Justin Timberlake when he came out
was like coming through the crowd and
all that and the big the big thing for
maroon 5 was he took his shirt off yeah
like that was the big thing right
I find maroon 5's music to be like
repetitive here's the 15 seconds coming
out of commercial for ESPN college
football you know what I mean like I've
never purposely listened to maroon 5 and
it's just like on the radio when I'm
talking about more important things
I don't know I just there was no moment
that was a great moment no I don't think
there was either I I get it but I die I
did enjoy it I'm not a maroon 5 fan I
feel like most of their songs sound the
same yes I still thought it was cool and
that was so and so much I thought they
both were yeah you're right they were
brief and there was that no polarizing
moment I get that too where you were
just like oh wow that was awesome or
what a disaster that was the moment was
really I felt like the Travis Scott
entrance but what I don't all right so
this is just something I thought about
as I was watching this first of all like
why all the pushback on maroon 5 for
doing the halftime show
so because the Kaepernick I understand
this so from the but why does Justin
Timberlake not get it last year because
he's just cooler no no no no so the real
thing is is last year Super Bowl was in
-24 Minnesota right where there's not a
lot of african-american culture right
Atlanta is the culture and they picked
some a group that is completely neutral
and has no like yeah it's just
completely disconnected and this was a
time that a lot of people thought for
them to reach out and either get an
outcast or someone that's true to
Atlanta because Atlanta has a culture of
music there's no music in man I mean
Prince was in Minnesota right but like
he was like my hometown Detroit or like
anything like that Houston Atlanta I'm
just saying that like from someone that
went to the parties last week and saw
the performers it was some of the
biggest names that I've seen at a Super
Bowl week because everybody wanted to be
in Atlanta yeah like this is a story oh
like Saturday night I went to a club
called compound yeah compound is like
outside Atlanta
it is so Atlanta that I saw two women
riding on horseback to the club Wow
I was the only white guy in the entire
Club and there were thousands of people
Sims right to the point where Odell was
in another room and he saw me and he
double taked and he went like that he
like kind of like what up and he went
like this and he kind of was like what
are you doing here and like I was I just
said to enum I was like I just hope
people don't think I'm a cop other than
that this has been great but like and
the meek Millz just hanging out and
cardi B is there they weren't doing that
in Minnesota
right I also got to see your boy I met
Kyle Shanahan for that sounds good you
got the city you got to watch a little
weight yes right and I'm telling you he
is a stand yeah he is a superfan yes
like at the end I looked over and like
Jed York is there too and I'm like Oh
Jed must love this amelie ginger cloves
of millet he has had no idea what's
going on but right when he got done I
looked over and Kyle is like fist
pumping he goes the best ever did it and
I was like yeah but I was like I'm not
gonna record him like I'm not gonna be
that guy but to see Kyle Jam and a lil
wayne' this guy it was a long time thing
for me always as yes so Robert Kraft
dancing with cardi B yeah that got a lot
of backlash too all over the place she
was it was it was at the wheels up party
on Saturday gotcha and he got up on the
stage and was going nuts gosh good video
yeah sounds good but I'm at the point of
my life no I'm my couch on Saturday
night was way better than all that um
dude I'm pretty much there was there
ever a time though where you were like I
still feel like I kinda want to go I I'm
like and did kids change that asking for
a friend
no I did no but I'm right around your
age where I feel like I started to make
that where I was just like I'd rather be
able to wake up at 8:30 I would be
perfectly fine if I was going to the
game on Sunday a do it just go to the
game on Sunday like okay let's sleep in
on Saturday and maybe we'll walk around
the city a little and did you go to
Super Bowls as a player and do radio row
and like pitch brands I did not really I
did one year I believe what brand were
you pitched oh wait so let me think for
you I don't know if I actually went to
like a play road though and how to do it
there I don't think I actually did that
like I went to Super Bowls and was paid
to show up but it's a few events to
answer questions and autographs and
things like that
but not like you weren't bitching all
this sighs no I don't think I got to
that caliber of a player to where they
were like we want you for the whole day
yeah and we're gonna pay you all sit
load of money no I never got that those
are for the special players the NFL
I got another pretty cool story so that
Friday night I hosted an event with
Adrian Peterson and David Johnson right
and again Adrian Peterson almost broke
my hand but he was wearing this jacket
that had this like fur boa like built
into it yeah and I was like bro where
did you get this jacket and I was
wearing that maroon velour shirt and he
touches me favorite he goes where did
you get this shirt and I was like Adrian
Peterson just touched me but I asked him
at one point you'll appreciate the store
I go what's the hardest you've ever been
hit in your life and he said I know
exactly the play he said we got the ball
in the 40-yard line and we're playing
the Ravens right and he's on the Vikings
at the time right and he hits a hole and
he goes I'm Adrian Peterson here's a
hole I'm on the four I'm walking into
the end zone right like he said it like
that and he started he said I he started
to come up in his stance and he got de
cleated and his feet come off the ground
and he had no idea what just happened
and when he looks up Ray Lewis is right
over him and he goes do not start
getting up until you cross that line and
in Peterson Tico's and from then on and
I stopped um I go you're telling me that
like seven eight years into your career
you got hit by Ray Lewis and completely
change your philosophy of goal line he
goes I never got up again because of Ray
Lewis is in the back of my head all the
time going you better not kid up yeah I
was like that's an awesome still being
like get up like start like when you
start like rise like kind of like
grazing into the end zone
yeah stuff lesson the hard way there
it's like cam learned it a few years ago
against the was that the Falcons Oh pump
racing in and Deion Jones side year
Hold'em um so when the game starts Sims
has a belief that he's gonna figure out
who he's rooting for after about I don't
know five minutes of gameplay right
where did you find yourself rooting on I
found my I was rooting for the Rams I
was rooting for them I did I stayed true
to it but I I will say this I was never
like as emotionally invested with them
as I was and other teams in years past
like did you work for the Eagles last
year I did I did I did I rooted for the
Eagles last year um but yeah I think as
the game went you know I think pretty
odd I'm pretty early on I thought well
the Patriots are better so I was not
like oh gosh this is horrible you know
it's one thing of our rooting for the
Rams and the game continues and
go the Rams are clearly the better team
here they should win this and they're
messing it up and then I'll get
emotionally more like right come on you
[ __ ] are but you really do root for
the better team I tried to because you
believe that in history we should be
remember that that's right and I think
as the game went on I was at very peace
with the Patriots winning the football
game and continuing to move the ball of
course hey I was just like everybody
else wanting a little bit more
excitement in the game but was really
enjoying the pressure packed moments of
having to micromanage a game where every
little thing mattered by both coaches
and you know I think that's where you
start I mean the start of the game New
England how they come out on that side
of the ball so upset the Rams deferred
oh I know I was not excited yelling I
know I was not expecting that but I
guess they thought hey let's get our
defense let's see if we can rattle Tom
and company ugly hick and they did they
got a pick certainly Tom's first pass
they did Wade Phillips deserves so much
credit for the defensive game plan what
was it what did you see I think they
didn't do anything crazy like I didn't
look at it and go oh this was but what
they did was disguises and gave Brady
false indicators and Romo said this
atmanand zone so give me give me some
things that you saw that were like I
like what waits dwell I just think that
at least he didn't make it where Brady
was like oh okay blue 45 okay single
safety oh its cover three all the way
here I got it it's cover three but
that's what I mean when you're watching
at home right what were you seeing like
were you seeing safeties drop biasing
and corners go across with wide
receivers like it was man-to-man but
then they were playing zone coverage
that's what got me on the pick no doubt
about it that's what got him a number of
time we Coleman drop back after falling
yeah he thinks that okay it's gonna be
man-to-man coverage here I shouldn't
have to worry about anybody buzzing
underneath cuz its man demand but now so
he gets the ball which is going to be a
quick throw and as he's throwing it he's
gonna oh damn this is not man this is
not man-to-man this is zone let me see
if I can fit it in there real quick and
of course he gets a hand on the ball and
the ball pops in the air right so it was
just that I think more than anything why
why isn't every defense that way every
game yeah I mean it does it take that
much longer it's a lot of coach
it is it is a lot to coach you know your
guys doing things that I know it's their
job but you're gonna have guys doing
things that are not necessarily
comfortable in either right like all of
a sudden Aqib Talib who's an outside
corner his whole life all of a sudden
falls under the cross now he's a nickel
yeah he's asked to know the zone rules
within the nickel but he hasn't had to
do that all year long and now it's going
now you gotta know all the zone rules
for the run game that pass game the
quick passes whatever it may be that's
why it takes a special coaches are
conservative like that too they don't
want to ask players to do things that
are outside their norm because they will
kill themselves when the game is over
when they ask a player to do something
he's not comfortable with or hasn't done
a lot and then he messes up in a big
moment they're gonna go up to him why
did I ask him to do that
that was stupid of me he didn't do that
all year so you've got to have a mature
unit and of course the two weeks of
preparation and things like that that
help out so you said Wade did a great
job
yes how much should we give to Belichick
how much do we give to Flores for the
defensive game plan and what did you see
as the defensive well yeah I think
Flores because he's your new coach of
the dog yeah Beefalo deserves a lot of
credit I mean from everything I know and
how things work in New England is be
flow comes up with the meat and potatoes
of the offensive game plan just like
josh mcdaniels would write but for
what's gonna go from there is he's gonna
have that game plan and then as they
watch film on the first day of practice
two weeks ago and things like that
Bill's gonna continue to dissect it and
pick up flaws and maybe we shouldn't do
this so in a weird way Flores handles
the install yes he goes this is what I
believe and Bill at this point trust him
enough right because he knows he
believes the same thing bill does at the
core principle so there's kind of like
when I when I see chefs and very like
great kitchens there's a bunch of people
that build it and then there's the chef
at the end that goes this needs to go
this way this needs to go that way
they're very close but it was a
finishing touch
gotcha right and then I'm sure bill
handles in-game adjustments I would
think so and him he's and Bill and for
as knows you know so he'll be he would
be something like hey B we got to change
you know blah blah blah to this blah
blah blah
yep you're right bill that's right I was
just kidding on that you know they're
there they're at the point where they're
probably very close to finish each other
sentences like
that way so Beefalo certainly deserves a
lot of credit but don't get it [ __ ] up
the best Oh John that TIA is Oh Bella
Jack what was the defensive game plan
like I said I was just reading about six
down linemen and the quarter cover
remember we talked about that a lot last
week right how we thought they would
play like the bear front tried to take
away well they didn't play necessarily
the bear front right so they played four
down front and they didn't necessarily
go you know Center and cover the two
grades they did like what you would call
an over defense where you have the shade
nose right yep so let's just say if
you're the quarterback and the tight end
is to the right and you're walking the
line of scrimmage okay yeah there's
gonna be a defense and you're left that
the tackle on your left is gonna be a
nose tackle shaded on the on the left
shoulder of your center then the other
demons a tackle was gonna be on the
outside shoulder of the right guard and
then the defense end over the tight end
to that side so the defense is playing
to the strong side trying to the strong
side they got four down linemen now then
they but Kyle van Noy on the line of
scrimmage to the weak side opposite of
the tight end so we have five down five
and then they brought Patrick Chum up to
be the guy who was over the tight end to
be the sixth guy he was on the outside
edge of the tight end so if they wanted
to play man-to-man he's there to cover
the tight end man and if they're playing
zone he's on the proper side for the
zone coverage as well and I also read a
lot this morning that this is very
similar to what Patricia did to the Rams
in week 13 I think it's all very similar
to what they did it was very effective
and very effective and would it be a
what does that do to that to the right
well so this is what it does to the
inside first all you got the guys
outside like van noe and Chung right so
not all those speeds sweet they have
enough speed or catch them right or see
it coming right because there's nobody
really blocking them they're kind of
free so if they see it coming they're
gonna cut it off and make you cut in
both two very good read and react
players phenomenal IQ is off the charts
for football at their position but it's
so fun member when the Eagles had Chung
he was so bad I know it's just it's just
more proof that in no other sport is
coaching more important yes coaching
knowledge of the swats Belichick yeah
that's why not just yeah it's Belichick
right exactly right so guys six guys
right and you
what was behind it so let's go to the
front for first because this is where I
thought it was really cool so now you
have those four now what did it do to
the other four guys you have the two
guys in the edge van noe and Cheung all
right are gonna try to funnel their
basically the edge setters yeah so now
your defensive ends
don't worry haft about setting the edge
you want to run inside zone they can
kind of attack and collapse the Delaine
so the romo kept drawing straight lines
a little bit I kept going there I'm just
gonna come in did not do their normal
New England let's to gap and ring it
they kind of played let's go to the one
gap and be aggressive and collapse the
inside zone running ski I feel like you
said this is that's the way to defend
the ranch for a long time is it's a way
to defend a lot of these type of running
teams it's really new England didn't do
this against Kyle Shannon and the
Falcons that's why they got torn up on
the run game a little bit because they
were trying to gap and they just left
too many holes so I bet you that was
part of their thinking too like damn
they're gonna try to do some of those
runs so we have to just play single gap
integrity defense and then off of that
hey we saw man-to-man for the majority
the interesting thing I thought would
the man-to-man was they like Gilmore on
Kooks just yet we expected they went JC
Jackson on Gerald Everett so this is
terrible have zero cat is nothing and
jerry' and in a heat covered Trevor
being covered Kelsey the week before
right now so they did that and then our
man Jonathan Jones in a lot of big
situations he would cover Robert woods
and they would have him because he's a
quicker type but a lot of the time
underneath helped him out if they were
playing man-to-man it looked like to me
that they doubled woods not because they
were necessarily like this is Robert
Woods we're gonna compare him to Tyree
kill he like that more because this is
Robert Woods and in big passing
situations he's usually the scheme guy
McVeigh makes it to where the plays
designed for him so they always had a
guy inside and outside on him the
Patriots also played probably more zone
than I saw them play all year but why
because one the run game we talked about
and my guess would be Belichick knows
the areas of the field that McVeigh
wants to it probably had a good feel for
the areas exactly right and the other
thing is Romo hit on this and I know
we've talked about the tight splits of
the
Seavers right when this receivers are
really in tight split sitar by man hard
to play bump right cuz the guy goes
across the formation the linebackers
everything it becomes a natural pick
right yeah so I think Belichick saw that
and said why would I do that to my guys
and and he goes I think I have a good
feel for what this guy calls exactly and
now he can drop people in the right
areas or and not be picked in case they
try to do too many man-to-man type
concepts McVeigh came out and took the
blame and got outcoached he's the man I
just got so much respect for him bro you
agree with the sentence yeah I agree
with it no no question I mean he was out
his answer to Belichick yeah well
because that's what you always see in
these cases is the evolution the second
third cry or the adjustments how did
each team adjust
I mean his answers I knew England never
really had to adjust on the defense it
sounded I felt like they had some
success with bootlegs he rolled out and
hit the guy coming underneath that was
few and far between and then I felt like
they had they took a few deep shots
right and there were opportunities there
there was they had Brandon cooks down
the sideline of course that was at idea
what was there their true answer those
for us I think there's the true
philosophy change for the Rams is what
you saw a little bit I'm gonna say what
was that maybe the second drive of the
third quarter where they stayed in the
huddle right and I don't know if you
heard Rommel talk about this but they
were staying in the huddle until 16
seconds instead of usually meaning the
Rams where they get up to the line and
they adjust they adjust they basically
said you know what we're never let their
adjusting better than us today and
they're on our stuff so let's just stay
in the huddle and when we break let's
get up there and see if our pace can
confuse them they did this a little bit
in the the Saints game filing when they
turn things around
let's stop their communication they
obviously have a good game plan let's
see if we can get up there and now with
the pace we can [ __ ] they're mad they're
you know talk and predication up to
where they'll mess something up of
course that did not happen and I'm also
thinking they probably had to do that
why because it was a damn Patriots home
game that's why I was walking around the
stadium and it was 12 to 1 Patriots
fence my friends from Boston in the
stadium be 100 to favor Bay thought it
was like definitely eight
24sure you know I had two friends who
texted me like pregame one was like it's
80/20 and then the other friend
responded on group text going I don't
think it's even that I think is ninety
ten yes you can just brought that up to
Melvin Ingram just about the Chargers
and he's not fueled by fan noise and he
acted like it was no big deal he was
like now where the snow here he did say
though about how it's a benefit it would
be a benefit but he didn't make a big
deal Sam said it would be so great for
your team because you'd be able to pin
your ears back that's when I felt like
he looked at us and was like Dan that
would help me out sure yeah I just felt
like he like almost downplayed it when
it really is a big deal it's just not
gonna make it or don't bang that's
that's you know that's what a real
football player would do it's just what
they do okay no that's we got a shitty
crowd and that's so what and we're just
gonna have to bless qui anyplace alright
so that was the adjustments and then how
did Bella check and the offense adjust
to what Wade Phillips did well to get
their touchdown the third quarter I
think fairly early on and they started
breaking some long runs to towards it
right right and I think fairly early on
when they realized okay Brady threw an
interception
next try Brady almost doing intercepted
a second throw then he fumbled about two
plays after that and they recovered it I
think at that point right there bill
said my defenses got them and I have
four running back second carries and I'm
not gonna let I'm not gonna let I'm not
gonna vom okay I'm not gonna let Tom
screw the game up but more importantly
I'm not gonna let Donald and Sue ruin
the game and I think that's really where
the game went back to I think no one
goes Kant came into this going we're
fine with 1710 we're gonna win 1710 but
I'm not gonna try to get into a 30 to 24
shootout with these guys and the game
becomes wide open because they got more
superfreaks than us and one of those
super freaks might make a play a moment
to turn the game so they went
conservative on them yeah how do they
stop Donald what was the game plan I
mean I think the thing you saw more than
anything a lot of the big runs was they
took advantage of them flying upfield I
just remember that first run we was like
it was the tight end coming and they
strapped him
like they dance OD Michelle got like 15
yards right sue was like 5 yards exactly
I think they let their aggressive and
again I'll give everybody a more more
definitive answers on the Wednesday pod
when I can really break this down but
yes and the long story short that looks
like what they did more than anything
you guys want to fly up field be
aggressive that's fine but we have so
many ways to run traps or what they
would call the Y Wham or the full-back
wham where you know you see grunt
kindness inch towards the center right
and Brady says set hut and then they let
that tackle to that side just defensive
tackle go upfield and he gets sideswiped
by a Gronk who's coming in from an angle
knock him out of the way and then the
ball just straight up field like a quick
hitter and quick you're welcome
yeah anybody that took the under Gronk
receptions over and Gronk yards over
after parlay that I didn't know yeah I
just like saying what I would bet so
that's on why Edelman was amazing and
they've done what they found a way to do
and how they get him oh where they did
they crack the code eventually was they
finally figured out like okay we got
them and some formations where we know
it's zone and more times than not like
you saw in a lot of his catches what
there was a few down the field that were
great and I'm not trying to take
anything away from that
but really the over the middle stuff was
they got him one-on-one with a middle
linebacker right more times than not and
six yards yes all those type of plays
the Rams defense was phenomenal come on
all the they were on the field a lot in
the first half it was 20 to 10 basically
in the first half 2 to 1 they were on
the field they don't substitute a lot of
guys they had a bad penalty on the drive
Gus Kowski missed the field goal because
they called the oh that was Green Pass
where the guy got hit like I did not get
Nicole Roby coming was it was like a
attack that was so stupid but right if
that would have turned into points I
would have been annoying right but
either way you know the Patriots played
conservative on offense and the story of
the Patriots all year has been their own
line and their running game and that's
what they played through and their
defense is really talented and they're
really good up front and what we said a
lot last week was it was a size or speed
matchup
and the size wore them down eventually
and it just they're just not enough
pliers on the Rams and there wasn't
enough offense to dictate the pace of
the game to the favorite they wanted and
the bigger more conditioned truest true
best fourth-quarter team I've ever seen
in the history of sports and I saw an
interview today with Belichick talking
about that that he felt like Josh sat
here and watched it with me where he
felt like the longer the game went and
the closer was that that favored them
yes and that they are the one of the
best condition teams in all the sports
it was cool to hear him say that and
they are like I've said then the only
team I freaking know that still runs
gassers and week eight and week 12 and
week 16 in the wild-card round they are
running gassers because they are not
going to die out in the fourth quarter
and overtime first Atlanta and that's
Super Bowl they never die out so I'm
very much into the wagering and gambling
and stuff I think what's so interesting
about it is there's analytics that every
different group of people that focus on
football has that the other groups don't
even know about the fantasy community
has so many analytics that they use to
chart how good players are this is the
first time I've heard about this should
have been score formula this is from the
VESA network that I was following around
they said what the score should have
been right what you do is you take
rushing yards many times it by two right
then you add passing yards multiply that
by 0.67 divide it by 15 and these should
have been score would have been I guess
don't tell me yet because then you're
factoring were you moving the ball and
then it looks at like missed field goals
or goes you would have gotten factor it
yeah I mean I guess I'm trying to think
it as a factor and plays like golf
missing cooks wide open down the middle
no it's it's more about like how
effective your offenses and points you
should get from an office right so the
score should have been 17 to 6 so they
got the score should have been 25 to 14
25 hadrian's okay and I should see that
yeah but I had never heard of that stuff
and that was interesting new one yeah um
what is the deal with Todd Gurley did
you guys see the McVeigh quote about him
no so let me just read this real quick
cuz I thought it was kind of weird so
McVeigh
said about girly I actually think it is
more of a result of the kind of
opportunities he had I don't want to
beat a broken record but the reality is
that we didn't get a lot of plays off in
general until you kind of get into some
of those unknown passing situations
toward the end and it seemed like we did
end up having success
Todd is healthy we just didn't really
get a chance to get anybody going today
offensively and that starts with me I
didn't really like what was he saying
with the first one well first of all
Judy's he had McVeigh with an amazing
Sims ISM beating a broken record
combining I don't want to be a broken
record and beating a dead horse
phenomenal but yeah what cuz it sounds
like he's saying I didn't call the plays
I think he's just saying they're often
Skinner got into a flow there read the
first part of again I didn't hear that
part of it I actually think it is more
of a result of the kind of opportunities
he had right I don't want to beat a
broken record but the reality is that we
didn't get a lot of plays off in general
until you kind of get into some of those
known passing situations toward the end
right and it seemed like we did end up
having success yeah they just said they
never he never got opportunities they
never got in the flow of the game they
never really got the offense going all
the things we worried about with the
Rams when we saw them lose to the Eagles
and the Bears right and their front get
pushed around it was an issue it was in
issued their front got pushed around
once again I mean Dante Hightower got
sacks right all of those things that he
was phenomenal I mean what how many did
that they ended up with what four were
sacks so for action and the Rams had one
on a body where Brady like sat there for
eight seconds I by a guy that I didn't
even know was on the right exactly right
me neither so there you go like I mean
it just showed you again the greatness
of that New England offensive line how
talented they are
but yes their offense never got going
Belichick was all over everything they
wanted to do and girly hey you know he
obviously does not look totally like
explosive 100% to me maybe this that's
the toll of the season caught up to him
I I don't know what other what else to
say but either way there wasn't a whole
lot of lanes to run through I don't give
a damn if they had brought back Barry
Sanders in them and Smith it was not
going to be a big rushing day read seven
people at the line of scrimmage right
they had to back people off in the
and that was infused by some of the zone
coverages and then there was a few third
and twos and third and threes where I
was yelling at the TV
[ __ ] run it run it on third and two
or three and three New England was
putting all these people the line of
scrimmage and dropping eight cuz they
were like we know you won't have the
balls to run it you're gonna pass it I
guarantee it that is one of the simplest
themes of 2018 right is the good teams
have the balls to run it on third
exactly right you have to and Bella
checks out there and said I'll put a few
people the line of scrimmage and play
the same look I've been playing but they
won't run it I know it here they'll
chicken out because that that offensive
play caller over there who loves offense
he's good about I'm calling a run on
third and three behind Austin Blythe
he's in a truss right he's gonna trust
I'm gonna give it to golf and my
receivers and my pie design and Bella
old Billy ball game was like oh that's
what I thought you do and I'm gonna have
eight guys and there's gonna be nowhere
to [ __ ] throw it is funny all right a
lot of it is funny that like third and
two has turned into a passing down for
most teams and a lot of teams it has yes
I know but even though you know if you
ran it on first and got four ran it on
second got four you could run it again
on third and get four but no now now
those last two it's easier to pass it's
amazing and that's we've I think
mentioned that a lot over the last five
or six weeks where New England is not
afraid of third and two or third and
three neither were your breakout team
yes
break routine because the Rams that felt
like always through one third and they
did a lot of times yesterday certainly
Josh knows me too well he put in the
rundown Jared Goff poopypants did you
see that report before the game oh no
England Patriots report there was a
report that came out before the game and
the quote was something like the
Patriots believed that if they keep the
ball on Jared scoffs hands Jared Goff's
hands he will poop his pants and lose
the game like that was actually in the
bleacher report alert yeah and I was
like alert to is a random alert yeah and
it was like a poop emoji in the alert
and I was like his left go a source now
on behalf of the Patriots they're just
gonna keep the ball on everybody
whatever I know like a quarterbacks
performance I usually say they poopy
pants yes you do i I really when you
watch the film yeah on that one third
and two right
he held it forever and then like Kyle
van Noy ran by and he just went to his
knees right and he didn't throw it away
right I really want to know what was
happening yeah there there was there
there was another throw down the left
sideline where I know Romo pointed out
like he was confused by the threat he
had the out cut to a woods open he
definitely did not have a good game I
mean there's no other way to say that
the ball came out of his hand funny he
was certainly confused at times yeah and
it was a good gait defensive game plan
as well but you know again again hey all
quarterbacks need help
certainly and and Jared Goff has still
has a bright future in front of them but
yeah that was a learning experience and
that was humble pie for him and Sean
McVeigh they both got their much looked
and I think they're just gonna have to
accept that and continue to build and I
think again it just shows you how like
special Patrick mahomes was the week
before right because life isn't wasn't
that easy either for him but he was
physically gifted enough to make four or
five plays in that game where you go
damn my offense got shutout yeah but
this dude is so frickin good that he was
still capable of scoring 31 points and
we really couldn't do anything other
than scrambling in a third and two and
throwing a bomb or a bomb the one bomb
the tyree kill or running down the
sidelines and throwing a piss missile to
a guy that had no angle to catch it and
where you know that's where a special
quarterback comes so I asked Kelsey
about Mahone right and I said I said you
know there's a lot of great players in
this league that don't ever get a
quarterback and now like you have
mahomes and he like looked at me and he
was like I feel like my career is just
starting yeah like he's like he's like
this is incredible yeah he's like he's
better than advertised man my mom's is
the first guy I could say that he could
throw for 60 touchdown passes i'ma call
on the shot right here like he can do it
because you how many times laughs oh
yeah here did I come away gun he left
some plays on the field especially with
the shovel passes and that Andy Reid
offense with a manufacturer that exactly
right I would not be shocked if he threw
for 60 touchdown pass here is my yearly
reminder to everybody about how unfamous
NFL players are I am walking down the
street with my friend Dan and his family
and we're walking down and who whizzes
by on a scooter
at about 25 miles an hour but tyree kill
and he's literally ting he's literally
wearing a ten
goodie that he probably got at some
event any whizzes by and I go Tyreke you
de man and Dan my friend Dan goes who
was that I know I was tired he'll he
goes really and he's just weaving it
down the streets and no one has any idea
who he is it's incredible the Super Bowl
is incredibly this is a funny level
we're walking a lunch on a Saturday
before I left and we walked past
Jonathan Ogden and no one was saying
[ __ ] to him and left going up doing he
was like isn't it crazy that someone
like you can walk down the street and no
one bothers you I didn't even say it I
said someone like you I go legend to the
game six feet eight no one's saying it
we saw Ebron no one said a word to him
and in Ogden just was like oh and then
started walking faster and then Josh
looks amigos I'm disappointed I didn't
recognize me me and Nina went to the EA
Sports party on Wednesday and it's just
dude
it was packed with NFL players yeah and
enums like I don't know any of these
people all right oh that's Kenyan Drake
and that stack Prescott you know like
there wasn't even a huge crowd when we
saw true Biscay on the sidewalk he was
like taking a picture with one person
but I did not feel like people were like
no really knew hell's he really got the
most reaction out of everyone that I was
around I could see that I mean he's he's
a little bit more in the pop culture and
everything to been in some big games
he's been on TV and a lot of big moments
here as of late yeah I mean he's the
best ident on the sport right right so
but yeah you're right it's amazing all
these and then okay so we get soma
Holmes went oh I know we have to do this
Brady now has six rings yeah Belichick
now has eight ring right to from the
defensive coordinator of the giant right
historically yeah and and I'll get to
Adelman in a second yeah Brady with six
come on man this is amazing what we're
seeing so I'm gonna continue to say
don't hate appreciate
everybody just accept it they're gonna
be back next year I'm gonna say this so
like it's amazing what they're doing is
the greatest dynasty in the history of
sports and American sports and Boston is
Titletown
and what the city of Boston is doing
right now
is off the charts I saw a video of
Boston fans leaving the stadium and it
looked like they were leaving a third
preseason game yeah they were just like
all right yeah yeah and I'm like
Philadelphia they greased poles because
they afraid of the cartage we are gonna
do and Boston is now at a point where
they're like all right where's the
trophy emoji so I can put one two three
four five six and then pose with my
family like it's so casual it's
incredible they're amazing they're I
mean it is they're spoiled but they
appreciate it they took over that
Stadium and they'll have millions
tomorrow for the parade in New England
so well they're amazing fans as
obnoxious as they can be at times and I
don't mind it because I feel like damn
if one of my if the yankees and giants
were that good I'd be just obnoxious
I'd be rubbed in everybody's face too so
I get it but it is a mean think about
this and what's amazing I mean the Red
Sox kind of did like to the Dodgers just
like the Yankees I mean the Yankees what
the with the Patriots into the Rams it
was like huh well four it would be over
little then clearly the better team and
we'll put you away when we're ready like
that's what they do it's just boys even
realize it was the same-sized it's
amazing right now with what they're
doing everyone is good a debate and and
sims's rules for quarterbacks and who's
the greatest of all time is different
because you're looking at ability and
you're also factoring in coaching and
all that stuff right and but I would say
that in terms of playing the quarterback
position yeah Tom Brady is the best
that's ever done it sure I mean you know
I am the mix of the inner intellect the
the comfort ability right the the the
consistency okay because when whenever I
hear from elite athletes yeah they say
that the number one thing that we always
talk about is consistent greatness right
and for him to do it this long it's it's
like LeBron the fact that these two
athletes yeah and I bring in like Roger
Federer right like just to this era
there's a there's a few guys in
different sports that have done it for
so long right and to be at that level
for so long is insane yeah I will say
this because it's so hard to separate
Brady and Belichick even though I give
like 75% to Belichick is when you think
about the greatest teams there's always
the Brack
of the beginning of it to the end yeah
so the Packers it's gonna be like
sometime in the 50s to sometime in the
60s and then the Niners it can be like
sometime to the 80s and it's like the
very beginning of the 90s right and the
Cowboys can be like to be the 90s until
like the middle end of the 90 yeah and
then you're gonna see the Patriots yeah
and it's gonna say 2001 right - right
and we're already at 2019 yeah so like
let's think about that like these teams
are doing it for six years eight years
you got teams like the Bears that was
like two years they thought it was gonna
be ten years like we thought that
Jacksonville Jaguars were gonna be a
dynasty we thought the Seahawks were
gonna be a dynasty but for two decades
as this for 20 years it's 20 or 30
Yankees it's 50 or 60 Celtics that's
what we're seeing and it's more than
them I mean it is it's and we could go
another five years and we could go a few
more years and it's in the only sport in
our country where everything is made to
be equal it's the every year only NFL
there's one team in the NFC South that
goes from worst to first who could it be
this year it's that's the theme of the
NFL yeah
who's gonna suck this year that's gonna
be great next year ya know I know
they're great ever again Brady is so
amazing Belichick is so amazing I'm
never gonna sit here and go Tom Brady's
the greatest quarterback to ever live at
no point so don't everybody tune into
ever think those words are gonna come
out of my mouth I'm just sorry there's
not gonna happen I say it every time he
wins a Super Bowl I feel like I come in
here and go I don't know so I mean that
performance yesterday I know left go he
won the game pros just him well I just
got an alert that said at that hundred
and forty five yards he had in that
first Super Bowl work I know I'm just
trying to put it into perspective
everybody he's awesome he's absolutely
amazing
he's I'll say this the greatest leader
to ever play quarterback position
that was beautiful he's the greatest
layer ever he's amazing
I I would dream to be him if I was
playing quarterback in football to watch
him in the locker room after the game
with the Super Bowl trophy right going
to guys that nobody knows yes and going
you got to hold this right he every
moment he has planned out in his head
he's just the natural
good guy he's not really is he's not
it's natural he's not he's uh
manufacturing it's really not there's
niceness in Tom Brady's eyes I've always
thought that from day one and when I met
him I guy I am I'm a big I guy and then
I followed the eyes with the actions and
his eyes and actions tell me he is a
good person and that's where he's
amazing and he would be if my son ever
played quarterback I would want him to
approach his career the way Tom Brady
has where you live it there's nothing
else to it you'll have plenty of time
when your career is over to do other
stuff whatever it may be but why you're
in it it's all about winning and being a
leader and working here I don't care he
never cares about the Pro Bowl right he
they not in this [ __ ] to win Pro Bowls
like I heard him say last we got here to
win championships but other great
quarter actually like I gotta get to the
Pro Bowl because it's good for my brand
Tom's like [ __ ] my brand I'm gonna go
back here and get back to work
because I want to win the Super Bowl but
I can hear him yelling on the sidelines
when they showed that montage in the
pregame stuff him being a leader telling
the offense like hey we gotta do this we
I do like that makes that makes the hair
on the back of my neck stand up when I
see that and that's where he is special
let alone the special talents he has
yeah and this still has a special arm
that's where it's amazing and he is a
all-time sports legend pantheon up there
with Jordan LeBron he's on your belly
Rushmore of quarterbacks though he's
definitely on my Mountain ok good I
always say he's the third greatest
quarterback for me of all time even
behind Rogers no no way doesn't it only
to and I'm not trying to again I don't
want to make this against time no no but
I do I think if you put those guys on
the New England Patriots they'd have the
Super Bowls too it's it's it's a team
sport but I would agree with you though
his leadership who he is as a person
he's Drive yes he's a lot like Kobe in
that regard
right where you know Kobe has five rings
and Kobe was the kind of guy that he's
nicer of course his team likes some more
I feel like Kobe's gotten nicer as he's
gotten older yeah and I feel like the
difference was is that Brady came out of
nowhere and was a six round pick and got
humbled from the beginning right and
Kobe was a guard that came at a high
school and you never
gar come out of high school and he was
also a thing of thing and we're gonna
Kobe discussion think about Kobe
everyone forgets is he's half Italian
yeah like he was raised in Italy yeah
and like there's a lot of European
players that have these attitudes and
stuff and I look at Kobe as half like
you're a PA in a way but I think Brady
is its special how could he not go home
and go I can do this for five more years
yeah like this team is not even close to
as good as the other teams that I've won
Super Bowls with I don't necessarily
agree with that I will okay well I would
say that's because I know you're gonna
say they have players on their team
right that we're gonna look back five
years from now and go ahead damn I
didn't factor in JC Jackson how good he
was back then exact I didn't factor in
the 10 guys in that front seven that
they rotated their interior office right
I got it but I'm also looking at Chris
Hogan with a loss of a step yeah
Edelman's the worst Edelman at this
stage of his career is the worst number
one he's had I would say for a lot of
those teams yeah Grunk that is nowhere
near all the other positions
yeah but then when you factor in how
Belichick handles it you get the Rex
Burkhead you get the Sony Michele you
get the James White it was a perfect
Patriots team it was cuz it was just
droves of human made for the playoffs
they were kind of different this year
they were made for the playoffs their
major single physical will control the
clock our defense could control the line
of scrimmage we got good shutdown
corners I thought that was where it was
interesting it was a lot like their
early 2000 teams it really was the teams
that beat the Panthers and beat the Rams
the first time around where it wasn't
about pizazz and everything like that
and as usual they played their best
football down the stretch you know I
thought Brady was funny
he's like December he's like yeah we
struggled he goes I don't really count
the Dolphins loss he said that he goes
cuz he thought of us fluky goes kind of
fluky he goes but hey you know the
Steelers game that was a tough one but
from that point on he goes we played
really good football and again the
Chargers the Chiefs and the ran one sec
can't even tell you what mom's eyes look
like still Aaron Donald and DOMA
consumes D for just in Houston Joey Bosa
mark
melvin ingram zero sacks it's amazing
zero sense amazing
Edelman wins MVP yep alright so cool I'm
happy okay
I'm happy for Edelman because I know he
lives so conflict' but it's conflicted
with anybody that positive for peds ah
this is then first Jewish Super Bowl MVP
but I'm Jewish
yes I didn't know that I heard him say
'la hi um at the end of the press
conference is hilarious is I'm just
telling everybody like one of my goals
is to get Edelman to teach Gronk how to
play dreidel I just think that would be
the funniest crime we like it my fingers
are too big to spin it but I just look
at Adelman and I am a little conflicted
yeah how Patriot is it that a guy is
suspended four games for peds and in the
same season win Super Bowl MVP second
time it's happened right for them well
Super Bowl yeah right it's really it's
amazing but Edelman I don't want to say
I don't like the PE D thing you know I
don't that bothers me to my core okay
he's still amazing he's an NFL legend
he's not an NFL Hall of Famer okay it's
not that's the discussion not not when
your Twitter his accomplishments I mean
roll balls don't care about Pro Bowls
but okay no all pros that hundred care
about that he's a hundred and
forty-eight on the all-time catch list
right he's two hundred and forty eighth
on the all-time yardage list so now he's
what a three-time Super Bowl champion
and a Super Bowl MVP again he's awesome
player for an awesome system D on
branches in a Hall of Famer but no he's
better than Fiat brand but he is but
either way again I'm just gonna say this
too in the Edelman Hall of Fame he's an
NFL legend and he's gonna have moments
where his name is going to come up as
you would say in the story in the NFL
because of the great catch yes against
the Atlanta Falcons and the shot he took
against the Seattle she was concussed
and still got the first down now that I
say that he was so huge in all three
Super Bowls no doubt so that so you got
that cuz he really was the guy in the
Seattle Super Bowl he
was he I mean especially again that was
twenty to ten the great Seattle defense
so ten point lead in the fourth quarter
and it was Edelman and Brady making
plays Wow
but to that okay so yes he's amazing but
again man there is so many great
receivers on this list of Hall of Fame
line right now I mean great receivers
and Edelman is awesome but he has to be
a part of a system Edelman's not like
Antonio Brown or Odell Beckham jr. or
Julio Jones where you just go again line
up set up saw outside and the best
corner takes you you'll beat them all
game or they'll have to double-team you
know that's not what he is but he's
still really good let me play devil's
advocate the Hall of Fame is not for the
best athletes regardless of scheme the
Hall of Fame is about the contributions
to the game the Hall of Fame is for the
best players ever and there's a lot of
other players you could put in Julian
Edelman position and they would have
that same success yeah but the Hall of
Fame is about like what you win and what
your statistics are they don't bring you
up and go he had a shitty offensive
coordinator for sixteen miles I get that
but you don't just get to go in because
your coach designed to play where you're
right no one in the middle of the field
I'm just saying so in his three Super
Bowl games he did not play in the one
game against the Giants in 2012 his
career rankings and here's what he did
in the Super Bowl I'm just saying when
I'm in circles yesterday 10 for 141 yeah
Seattle nine for 109 in a touchdown
Atlanta five for 87 and one of the
biggest catches the game yeah so that's
what I'm saying though about the Hall of
Fame
I'm not ranking wide recievers but when
a career is over
you look at the collection of things
they did it is about the hardware in the
man but you're giving him the
opportunity because he has a great team
that's the unfair [ __ ] that's that's
what I said Travis Kelce about playing
with mahomes that's not real [ __ ] though
that's not a Hall of Fame player he
might have maybe had a Hall of Fame
storied career but that doesn't get you
in the Hall of Fame so maybe somebody in
the Hall of Fame that has had a similar
career to Julian Edelman that you don't
think should be in the Hall of Fame I
don't know I can't think of that but you
have to give me some names or I have to
look at that people that were part of a
system I guess you know you can tell the
story of the NFL without Julian Edelman
yes I don't think that's the end of be
end-all be I'm not ready to come up yet
some of those games because there's some
of the legendary plays but just
you had a legendary play doesn't mean
you are going into the Hall of Fame my
point I'm just saying is I don't even
think Juliet I'm gonna at this point of
his career I think he's got to put a few
more years up and he's got to rise up
those ranks I'm just saying though when
it comes to the Hall of Fame
you know they just bring up they bring
up statistics and they bring up
accomplishment right it's not about who
you play with and that chicks are gonna
be less then yes he's two hundred and
forty eighth all-time on the you
receiving yards left yes I said right
and now that's gonna get in and then his
receptions go to that I'm not right
hundred and forty fifth or something
like that right but you got to remember
he's getting he's up there in years you
know he won a number of years and how do
you sit behind wes welker a via special
teams guy he's tied for 148 on the all
times receptions list with 499 catches
he's got cliff branch and been coach Wow
well he's would be 33 in May so he's got
like two or three more years love in so
I guess you know he doesn't mean it's
not legend not trying to be a hater on
Julian Edelman I'm just trying to keep
it real for my expertise which I am a
[ __ ] expert whether you like it or
not there's nobody that's followed
football as hard as me since four years
old there might be a few that can
compare and they're up there with me but
I'm just telling you you ask any of my
friends or family history of football
pulling up numbers pulling up players
I'm pretty damn good okay he'll be in
the Jewish exponent Hall of Fame first
Bernie Kosar high yeah and Sandy Koufax
buddies he's amazing uh-huh and there
that's all there is to say about that
I'm at Trillo Brady Gronk Edelman yes
that's a Hall of Fame tree oh that's
special that's one of the best trios
we've ever seen you talk about guys that
get the most out of their ability
yeah the sport clutching big moments yes
man that's I mean Gronk inand Brady of
course our boys they're boys and they
are all Psychopaths yeah and they live
it they live it yes they really is every
day it's about getting better I'm gonna
eat this I'm gonna workout that I'm
gonna think about this whatever it is
and that's what I love about that all
right you were mentioned we were talking
about the Hall of Fame do you have the
class that went in this year for the
Hall of Fame what was really cool is we
did three interviews and again I'm going
to
putting these interviews out in the
upcoming weeks but we did a full one
with Champ Bailey a full moment I lost
and a full one with Ed Reid awesome all
three got into the Hall of Fame yeah so
the Sims and left go blessing I think I
think we helped class this year Champ
Bailey Pat Bowlen Gil Brandt Tony
Gonzalez Ty Law
Kevin Malloy Edie Reed and Johnny
Robinson yeah so what was really cool if
you were following Bleacher Report's
Instagram and I believe we're gonna have
more videos coming out of this is we had
access to a number of these guys to see
our good friend David Baker Andre the
Giant 2.0 knocking on the door and like
saying hi to people and Ty Law was the
coolest I thought Kevin muwaiya was oh
yeah he was great to have him oh I broke
down and the thing is is Ty Law and
those guys at Ty Law got emotional too
because he didn't get in last year and
that was great champ I could feel it
like the weight came off his shoulders
and Reed came out their light was I'm
ready to go
but that said Reed he knew he was
getting it yeah of course you did but
it's the guys like Kevin oh why I always
say this there are certain guys that
when they're still playing are often
referred to as future hall-of-famer and
we say this as though it's guaranteed
and boy does it happen offensive lineman
a lot Allen Faneca it was said about him
all the time it worsened there's a
little loud John and logjam it online
yeah ol line the guards but when they
were playing in year 13 it was future
hall-of-famer Alan Faneca and now those
guys waiting right Kevin below I had to
wait yeah you played I believe with Ken
Wyatt Tennessee I just remember every
time playing Madden and going if I'm the
Jets I know I got 98 overall keb mo
Wyatt Center that's look at that's all
I'm and I ever played this I mean it's
not even that's not debatable I saw him
do stuff and I know skinny now with that
yeah yeah with that Chris Johnson team
and CJ 2k and how he handles people you
know how I was used to talk about how
like you get underneath there and you go
can this guy really snap me the ball and
block that I that freak that's in front
of me that's 320 pounds and he was
amazing and he could do it any which way
possible he was like the crafty veteran
that has every move in the world the
toughness and I've told you nobody in
that
some bad mofos on that Tennessee Titan
defensive team Kevin muwah controlled
the locker room nobody was a mess with
Kevin well why he had lasted if the
radio need to be turned down
Kevin why I said turn it down did that
defensive line turned it down the size
of his head yes it's a cinderblock it's
incredible
yes but I think it's a it's a really
cool class I think ed Reid champ and Ty
Law getting in together no so glad tile
all got in yes I mean he's a Hall of
Fame corner there's no doubt about that
I was really nervous team or needs to be
the next one to get him from New England
Richard Seymour is one of the greatest
defensive lineman in the history of the
NFL you got to get him in the sacks are
never gonna say it he is he is a [ __ ]
the play up master he was a mismatched
nightmare and he's one of the biggest
humans ever that was just like it
wherever he went
Oakland New England he was incredible
incredible I just love watching guys cry
on David Baker shoulders because Ty Law
looks like a child he does David Baker I
want to say this David Baker does an
amazing job at capturing the moment
think about this David Baker was also
the guy with his white gloves that took
the ball from Drew Brees and said we
will put this in the Hall of Fame we'll
take care that man when the ball is
we're gonna we're gonna capture your
legacy forever and keep it yes for
safekeeping so beautiful and and he
cares about it and I and I think it
makes the thing so special but Pat
Bolin's family congratulations to them
it stinks it was posthumously but the
three corners Kevin Moe I Who am I
missing
Gil Brandt Gil Brandt Legend all times
scout that you talk about the stories of
the NFL yeah he's been a part of
capturing them the entire time and his
eye for talent is it needs to be
rewarded still pretty damn good yeah and
even though I don't even sure how far I
can see anymore but yeah and I mean that
funny because I know Gil and if he's not
listening to us but that would be Johnny
Robinson and Johnny Robinson I don't
know the story of the Chiefs right I had
to look it up too
I was like yeah and but yeah played for
the Chiefs I think it was before they
even won a Super Ball if they look at it
up he's 80 he's aged born in 1938 a 1938
it was he on the Chiefs team that won
Super Bowl four let's see here so he
played for the Chiefs from
1963 right through 1971 okay so he was
he made that team because that team won
in 70 and he was on the Dallas Texans
from 1960 to 1962
well that became the Kansas City Chiefs
the Dallas Awards yes our official yes
Patrick mahomes right as we told you all
year PP well not as we told you here
we thought the universe was aligned for
drew Brees yeah but then the universe
Kubelik yeah the once I started getting
death threats to make mahomes MVP and
Sims winner of the betting segment done
Sims left ko ha ha
Erin Donald wins Defensive Player of the
Year say qualms Barkley wins Offensive
Rookie of the Year / Baker Mayfield
which I think made complete sense
Odell called him up and called him say
quads Barkley we had awesome that's cool
then who won Defensive Rookie of the
Year
Darius Leonard Darius Leonard that's the
one that we have an issue with yeah I
don't love that one because to me I want
to go that's where I just look at the GM
there Ryan pace and go damn look at all
the players that were acquired there let
alone him hiring that Negi he deserves
that I could have got coach of the year
a few different ways I mean I certainly
could have gotten Anthony Lynn or Frank
Reich I think over Matt Nate I would go
Bill Belichick or listen I mean you're
right that's he's kind of in that it's
unbelievable he's in the Jordan LeBron
stratosphere did he win it when they
went 11 and 5 with Matt Cassel I don't
believe he did like I know he I don't I
know you know what let me say this when
we talked about the Edelman MVP maybe
they need to open up coaching to the MVP
because the MVP last night was Bill
Belichick and Brian Flores and what they
did that was a historic performance by a
defense in the year of Oh points 54:51
offense fantasies awesome fantasy
receivers 5,000 yards let's throw the
throw let's throw it and New England
just set up yours defensive struggle
Mike Smith was coach of the year in 2008
Wow Wow
okay Michael Turner a check but two
to that point that's why I don't think
it was a great Super Bowl though yeah
and the reason is was it it's there was
never the big adjustment that showed me
greatness from both teams one team came
out there the game plan and the other
team couldn't adjust to it and I find
great Super Bowls or when it's a
constant chess match and that to me was
I made one move and then they couldn't
figure it out for 60 minutes and as
we're recording this it's official
the new head coach of the Cincinnati
Bengals is Zack Taylor yeah and I think
it's very interesting the day after this
young one Durkin has taken over the NFL
and caused Matt Lafleur Kliff Kingsbury
and Zack Taylor to get head coaching
jobs that offense was held to three
points he's gonna go I knew Sean McVeigh
but I didn't make this game play enough
Cincinnati fans this is all Sean McVeigh
I didn't do it right
but yeah it's it is very interesting it
was a culmination that did not match
what the rest of the season was that's
right it was just very atypical for this
type of season yes it was it was
atypical and I'm still not worried about
Sean McVeigh the body of work still says
he's special
they know yeah they got cold on offense
as the year went along it certainly he
had to manage the team a little
differently you know their offensive
line got exposed a little bit you know
their offensive line is not some great
unit okay they didn't beat the Dallas
Cowboys because they were just blowing
Cowboys off the line of scrimmage
they beat the Cowboys cuz McVeigh
schemed them up and found found
discrepancies and deficiencies within
their run game fits that expose them so
yeah you know we always talk about
you're gonna meet your match at some
point or another and the Rams finally
met that team that was just too much for
them to overcome I'm just curious if the
Belichick curse now starts for the RAM
so what I mean by that is when you face
Belichick in a big game right and he
shows the way he is choosing to beat you
yeah be prepared for the rest of the NFL
to figure it out there's a reason
Atlanta's defense wasn't great the year
after the Super Bowl yeah because
everyone kind of figured it out there's
a reason people knew how to attack this
Seattle defense after the Super Bowl
because everybody kind of figured it out
now there's a game plan set the edges
with some people drop back in his own
give Jared Goff some weird looks and
take away pace right and now we're gonna
watch to see if Sean McVeigh can adjust
and he will I believe he will yeah
because Sean McVeigh is man enough to
get on the stage and go it was my fault
and he's also a good enough worker that
he's gonna get back into the lab and be
crazy yeah and it's not just cuz he
looked at me and said left go and he
like made me feel like the most special
human ever but it's definitely up there
yeah pull up the teams yep they're out
okay looking at next year yeah who are
the teams that you're looking at as the
true Super Bowl contenders and I have
the updated odds after the Super Bowl
for what their new odds this is an
annual tradition if you thought that you
were gonna be able to leave this podcast
without predicting next year Superboy
you were just mistaken just 12 months
ahead of time yeah no idea about fridge
and see draft injuries doesn't matter it
doesn't matter just make your freakin
pinion
I'm picking the Chiefs just so you guys
know you're bringing the Chiefs and the
Chiefs are one of four teams tied for
the lead at seven to one odds I'm gonna
say it's bears Chiefs Nagy's gonna have
to play Andy Reed in the Superbowl Bears
chairs Chiefs that's what I'm gonna go
with next year that's my Chiefs are 7 to
1 and the Bears are part of them the
next two at 12 to 1 12 to 1 yeah I want
to say Bears Chiefs the Colts scare me
cuz they have a ton of money Colts are
really juicy at 22 whoo Pittsburgh still
scares me especially if they keep
Antonio Brown but Vicksburg is right
after the Bears at 16 to 1 ok yeah I
mean there's still some stuff to be seen
there but yeah I'm gonna go with Kansas
City Chiefs where's Bears I can already
see the storyline I feel like just put
it in the book start it up see you there
in Miami I'm gonna post that on
Instagram later today Chiefs the Bears
who are the teams that you're interested
in can the Saints do it after two years
of this things are done you think
they're done I know that's what kind of
not almost a third off a cliff well I
don't want to say they're done but I
just filling her name that's a lot to
overcome those last two years it it
feels a little bit like the Vikings a
little bit you know what I mean we're at
Yeah right Rams Saints Chiefs and
Patriots are all seven to one chargers
and bears are twelve to one Steelers are
16 to 1
Eagles are 18 to 1 Packers and Cowboys
Vikings and Colts are 20 to 1
you're Eagles will be in the mix Ravens
are 25 to 1 and two teams that I find
very interesting just from a longshot
perspective Seahawks and Texans are 28
to water Seahawks and Texans are just
teams that you know if the if
Schottenheimer can grow the offense and
and employ more of a play-action passing
game I thought their defense surprised
some people and I thought that Russ
Russell Wilson deshaun Watson I'm
looking for people that can buck the
trend yeah you know but at 28 to 1 both
of those look good and your boy Kyle's
coming in at 30 to 1 I can see that and
yeah
like we said let me were down there - I
don't know realms are 32 elena's Atlanta
went healthy and I think they made the
appropriate it moves on offense and
defensive side of the ball I mean
there'd be a team that I certainly say
watch out for who do you believe has the
worst odds to win the Super Bowl next
year the worst odds and I think that's
the Arizona Cardinals they are at 100 to
1 they're not even in the bottom for the
Bucks the Bucks are 75 to one wait so
you're saying there's a team with worse
odds to win the Super Bowl than the
Cardinal Raiders the Raiders are one of
the 125 to 1 goals Raiders Bengals and
Jets are all 125 to 1 but there's one
team at 150 to 1 and that is your Brian
menorahs led Miami dogs it's not to go
there because we don't know who their
quarterback can I don't know their
quarterback their coach yeah their whole
team is under sir I know that'll change
again here shortly I'm sure maybe once
they figured once they get Nick Foles
oh I hope so that's right anything else
from the game that you saw or they want
there was not a single commercial fl100
commercial oh that was great that was a
Grand Marshall yeah there was a few here
and there but the NFL 100 commercial it
was cool when Aaron Donald go was just
12 in the table and he goes what you
what you know about ninja bukka's
I thought that was hilarious I laughed
out loud there was a few that I thought
were pretty good but that's that then I
have felt 100 there was two of them
right there was one pregame I mean she's
a version that was good and then you saw
the long one at the end but they were
amazing yeah I can't read blowing yeah
yeah I read that to shoot that because
they couldn't get everybody all in one
place because there was so many people
right that they had to set up that
Ballroom in different locations around
the country and just like one camera
angle of it with one guy and extras in
the background and I just go to the next
look right what was your take and the
Josh this is more for you what was your
take of Atlanta as a Super Bowl City now
that you've been off what was my take on
Atlanta as a Super Bowl City so I love
cities that have downtown stadiums
because I just like all the energy of
having it action-packed yes downtown it
was luster yes but I just don't really
like downtown Atlanta all that much I
just didn't find it to be that great of
a place but it was definitely better
than having to take a train an hour to
go see the Superbowl like Santa Clara
but yeah I just don't really downtown it
laughs the thing about what's we're
about downtown Atlanta is a lot of the
restaurants are outside yeah a little
bit outside um once you're downtown you
can't leave because the traffic was
insane yeah that is always annoying what
about the radio Rose set up compared a
lot better than Minnesota
way better the radio Rose setup was
great the thing that jumps out to me
about Atlanta more than anything is I
think it's the nicest people in the
country Elena I've been around that city
a number of times and I don't know just
couldn't be a more pleasant vibe
everywhere you go everybody's calling
you hon and just yeah I don't feel like
it's sweet like I just feel like it's
natural niceness I've been to other
cities I mean hey listen we know in the
north or the Northeast people gonna be
[ __ ] in general I've lived in the
south in certain areas where people say
go you know bless you and then you walk
away make our [ __ ] about you three
seconds later I just never get that vibe
in Atlanta shout-out to the good people
of McCormick and Schmidt's that's right
CNN Center which served me I think four
of the six dinners that I had I believe
me as well yeah that's where you guys
kept going yeah because it was just
right there so I fell off the wagon I
was ordering lemon pepper wings at like
two forty five in the more
every way we got done with the show I
had no idea where you were a little
different experience yeah I'm also you
know I'm trying to because my thing is
like we talked about these guys all the
time yeah and I want to go and I want to
hang out with them sure I mean sort of
like to kick it with Kittel and Trent
Taylor and you're like I don't like we
tweet I message those guys all the time
you know what I mean yeah we also have
to mention Quinton quit Mountain was
incredible shout out to like Trent
Taylor like lying to me and getting out
there what's so funny about the Quinton
Nelson thing is Sims the amount of Colts
reporters yes that have been tweeting
right why didn't we get this Quinton all
year I I don't want to make this like a
thing like about like the profession but
I just don't think a lot of people talk
to these athletes like they're humans
yeah and and they don't realize that
he's like a 22 23 year old kid and they
ask him questions about what's your
responsibility offense and they they
never it they just don't get comfortable
with the guys and that's what we do you
know like when Derwin James comes up
there he doesn't want to leave he wants
to watch the 50-yard throughout 2001
Chad are there they hang around for an
extra thirty minutes even though they
have to be on inside the NBA level
around and it's late eldorado so awesome
so good but no it was it was cool to be
around the athletes and actually get to
meet the guys because you really don't
see these guys with their helmets off no
you don't ever and and the football is
an NFL the Superbowl is a cool
collection of all that so yeah I got the
mean Odell Beckham jr. oh oh okay I want
to dress that what good people I want to
say that Sims it's the first time I've
ever seen him fanboy yeah we're to the
point where 15 minutes before Odell got
there he like looked at someone and said
you're wearing the Odell Jersey but give
it to me cuz I'm getting it signed and
I'm taking it to my son and it's mine
and I was my dad and I was like wow like
but he met Odell and Odell walks in he
goes oh my gosh oh and I'd never seen
you like that he's them how did he get
to that point for you well I you know
how he got to that point to me I think
that first of all he's special as a
player I see the greatness in them I
mean he's he has a chance to be the
greatest receiver in the history of
football or at least in that
conversation he's that
but talent and then I think just like
anything what got me to be a huge LeBron
James fan or even a Tony Romo fan is
that gets sick of the haters I just get
sick of it and I go you know what the
other way I go the other way I go damn
like we're gonna hate on LeBron gene
ever wins the big game but he brings a
bunch of liars that nobody [ __ ] can
even remember from last year to the
finals yeah oh and Tony Romo oh all he
does is go eight Nate all he does is go
ain't Nate and I want to be a cup he
goes eight Nate because they would be
three and thirteen if it weren't for him
yeah but he makes magic and the fourth
quarter over and over and that's what
happened to me with Odell not only the
greatness of the player but I got sick
of the unfair criticism that we've stuck
up for with him so much and so often
they were great people hotel and his
mother and you could see really are
Odell gets his speed from and his
handsome good looks it's his mom sorry
dad
the one thing I'm gonna say so we're
gonna we're definitely having big [ __ ]
on Wednesday I don't know I gotta
confirm it okay I mean nothing all week
within that doggone free game and I'm
busy I'm busy I got a workout tomorrow
and then I got to work out the skin and
then I got a workout on Wednesday do and
I don't know if I can make it any I'm
busy maybe we should just go do the
podcast at Parisi's on one oh I'll be
you watch it'll all come down to whether
he can figure out his personal time
which is so funny he is such a devious
executive time so either way Sims is
gonna break down Phil and we're gonna do
that Wednesday and then we're gonna do
the fan mail bag josh will put out some
social later in the week and what kind
of round it up that way so we're gonna
have a few more home before the music
I'm not gonna act like this the Oscar so
don't play it yeah code time music off
the only thing I want to say is this is
that I go back to beginning working with
Sims doing 30 videos a day in a room
where we really didn't have any rules
and it was just like we would do 30
videos and would go here are the three
things that Giants have to do in the
offseason and me and Sims would be in a
room for eight hours and what's
incredible is it was kind of the minor
leagues where we kind of like learned
all the teams together
like we would sit there and like like
canvasser and everybody would help us
out but really like we're sitting there
going what should we do here right and
we would just kind of do all the videos
and at that time Sims and I would look
at each other and we would go who is
watching this clap like and and I
genuinely don't think anybody was
watching it now we do get some people
that go I remember watching those videos
the true like Bleacher Report team
streamer right but there was just a
point of contention for me for so long
where I would watch people on television
and either they'd be saying something
that sim said a few weeks beforehand or
they'd be saying something that was so
like wrong that I felt like I was going
crazy and I felt like you thought you
were going crazy too like the first two
three years of us working together we
didn't like the podcast I kind of just
getting started and we felt like we were
just talking like see how scout and
beige it and all that [ __ ] but really
like we were just doing these videos all
the time and now I look back at that
time ago what a waste but I'm so happy
that that I wasn't crazy yeah you know
what I mean
like I genuinely believe I know I say
this all the time that no one can watch
more filming Sims because there's only a
certain amount of hours of the day and
that's what you do and you're amazing at
thank you you were gonna now tell them
Wednesday where you're going in all that
[ __ ] but so happy I love you too proud
of you I didn't say it so you
technically said it first I love you too
I love you I love I love you and when
your upper lip gets big all right one of
my abilities yesterday for the Super
Bowl
thank you feeling better yeah when when
they started singing the national anthem
and I saw Brady like his eyes get teary
I didn't get it on camera no but my kids
they get such a kick out of but I get oh
yeah yeah no but III mean this I look
around the football space and this is
unique but you you are unique thanks man
I'm excited you're unique okay all right
so Wednesday we got to show Thursday
mailbag make them awesome questions but
again Sims and Lefko we're never leaving
you you don't think that the Sims left
go Instagram is still gonna have funny
moments as Sims on it you bet your ass
it will because it's Sims in left cone
but we're gonna we're gonna
keep this thing going because it's too
good to stop and y'all are the [ __ ] and
the homies to everyone that was in
Atlanta so everyone that's been deeming
us or messaging us about how great our
content was last week come on man we're
gonna keep this [ __ ] roll for Simms
peace out homey your fender good evening
everybody lef koe man holla holla holla
at you guys
on Wednesday